we are seeing more and more enterprises
embracing a hybrid and now increasingly
multi cloud strategy for their
applications beat on Prem and cloud or
even deploying components between
multiple cloud vendors developer needs
tools and agility to embrace hybrid
environments so they can handle real
time scale that's available across the
world data Stax is a masterless active
Everywhere database built on Apache
Cassandra and designed for hybrid cloud
DSE active Everywhere architecture
enables customers to build a consistent
operational data layer across on-premise
hybrid cloud and multi cloud thereby
eliminating data silos and accelerating
hybrid multi cloud deployments data
stacks enterprise is a foundation for
building highly distributed real-time
applications that need infinite
scalability no downtime and global
availability in any cloud and now with
Google Cloud Data stacks can provide
more flexible ways to create seamless
Enterprise clusters across different
regions using we amps and kubernetes
deployments active Everywhere capability
of data stacks Enterprise supported with
Google's global network enables
real-time applications across the globe
but the power of Google Cloud for DSC
doesn't stop at reams and deployments
it's also about security at all layers
of the cloud it's also about
manageability Google cloud provides the
leading managed production ready
environment for containers and it's also
about the network backbone that Google
has of thousands of miles of fiber-optic
cable that make multi-region data stack
deployment much easier than other clouds
with gke
on-premise our customers get the google
kubernetes engine experience directly in
their data center gke is production
ready and reliable for DSE to deploy
either on-premise or in GCP therefore
providing customers a very strong and
efficient hybrid cloud solution
something that enhances the data stacks
hybrid story that customers need today
now like most companies data stacks
wants to find the most customers that we
can help with
offering and for this we can turn to GCP
marketplace this marketplace allows
developers to find the solutions for
their projects with AI power
recommendations in product marketplace
windows and available free trials with
just a few clicks you can get data
stacks enterprise deployed quickly to
your project trusting that the image has
been verified against one er abilities
and optimized to run on GCP check out
the links in the description below for
more information and don't hesitate to
reach out to us with any questions you
might have
thanks for watching
you